we're continuing our extended
conversation with congressman Eric's
wawel Democrat of California so you've
talked a lot about Russia but you also
become known for your position on guns
and you're one of the very few Democrats
I think who's been honest about that you
say that the US government ought to ban
a certain species of rifle you wrote a
piece about this it's not a secret of
you you have you wrote it in USA Today
and you say this we should ban
possession of military-style
semi-automatic assault weapons we should
buyback such weapons from all who choose
to abide by the law and we should
criminally prosecute any who choose to
defy it by keeping their weapons so we
should confiscate this entire class of
firearms what do you think would happen
if the federal government tried to do
that well Tucker did you read the op-ed
I did I just quoted from it extensively
I'm not calling for a confiscation what
I'm saying is we should invest in a
buyback that we should restrict any
weapons that aren't bought back to gun
clubs hunting clubs shooting ranges keep
them there where is safe not on our
streets and if you were caught just like
if you were cut you know with drugs or
anything else they had probable cause to
go into your home and you had one of
these weapons yeah you'd be prosecuted
I'm not i've never suggested sending
troops I'm gonna quote collect animals
garrix wawel is your congressman from
California I need until Quebec in the
screen please I'm just gonna note once
again and we should buy back those
weapons and I'm quoting criminally
prosecute all criminally prosecute any
who refuse to who choose to defy it by
keeping their weapons so you're gonna
prosecute people who don't keep up their
weapons that's gun confiscation if
they're if they're caught with them yeah
not what do you think would happen I
mean do you think because of course the
overwhelming majority of those people
are law-abiding I have committed no
crime had no plans to commit a crime you
would instantly turn them into felons do
you think that you would have a civil
war are you worried about that what do
you think will happen if we do nothing
you've any more kids will be killed I'm
not I'm not you think you can answer to
be shot up more churches with arguing
about who's pushing everything I'm
critiquing you not very specific
suggestion for what we
your lawmaker so it this is meaningful
what you said and I trust the American
people are law-abiding that their
weapons could be bought back or keep
them at a gun club you don't have to
give it up what are you going to keep in
your home and you've done nothing wrong
you haven't hurt anybody and now you
just made them into felons yeah no it
there's no troop round up here Tucker I
just made them into felons you just said
that in the piece look I'm not I'm not
making this up but you wrote that so
what do you think like if I'm a gun
owner and I have one of the weapons that
you say should be banned I don't feel
like you're bringing it to a gun club I
feel like keeping it in my bedroom
closet I don't think you're giving the
American people enough credit that
they'd be law-abiding that they would
they would obey you
well not criminally prosecuted I'm
suggesting we have a conversation in
Congress and pass a ban like this they
would be obeying the law would you apply
as written by you know these passed by
would you drive these standards to
yourself and your fellow members of
Congress absolutely okay so cops though
I don't think cops should so your
bodyguards could have any kind of
bodyguards everybody who I was there
today there today I don't personally
have bodyguards oh but you're surrounded
by them
bodyguards that I pay for and they're
police officers they're sworn or trained
there to protect you they're in they
Shanti be outgunned and that's the
problem I have two brothers
my dad was a cop there out bodyguards we
get to have any kind of gun they want to
protect you but I wouldn't have him to
protect me I wanted to protect the
people who are getting shot up in a
school is that's not no capital police
it's to protect you you know this is
what about Capitol Police well no but it
is those schools they're afraid to go to
school tomorrow right if you're a book
driver but hold on they think shooters
walking into the classroom don't they
deserve to be protected they do and amen
an ar-15 I don't know why you need that
your house you have them in your in your
building where you work
police officers no your bodyguards don't
denigrate the cops narrating they work
hard there they shouldn't be outgunned
in there outgunned right now wait a
second I went to the funeral for four
police officers range killed - I don't
actually care more than I do we care the
same so it's not a question okay do you
think cops should have guns
I think that your bodyguard should have
the same guns that I have to protect my
friend well they're America's bodyguards
Tucker they're not they're gonna grate
them like that they come to my house
however check my wife on that well if
you call the police yeah oh but can I
have a capital help when you go to work
just protecting the constituents they're
protecting come in actually I don't know
why not hold on why shouldn't my wife
have the same firearm at home that your
bodyguards used to protect you is that
fair is that unfair why it's a
ridiculous argument why it's absolutely
important than me no I don't you are
trying why should you get to protect
your Clerk pots should not be outdone
here iam not our cups to our military
should be outgunned you're cops you know
police have why don't we just limit them
to the same hook and I can have at home
why can't we do a conversation about
this is a conversation why is it
nonsense you're putting your life you're
calling bodyguards and that's
disrespectful at least week was last
week they were all here entitling you're
honoring the fallen and you're calling a
bodyguard I'm calling here my dad was a
copy he's on a bodyguard no no he
protects people do you have maps
ridiculous you members of Congress have
bodyguards I noticed we're current I'm a
bodyguard man that is so disrespecting
are no government's offices for them
families they can I get the same and
Miley shouldn't be outdoors you can pay
for it they shouldn't be out kind of gun
did a question yeah um if I walk down
the hallway in front of your office you
have officers there paid for by tax
there's great guys I'm not attacking
them obviously and I think they want to
attack you for that they're not at all
I'm merely saying that you have better
protection than I do and you're saying
that my family doesn't deserve to have a
certain species of weapon you get to
decide what we can protect ourselves
with but you're not gonna in any way
take the ability to protect you away
from the Capitol Hill police I'm saying
that every police officer in America
today is outgunned
for their safety and for the safety of
people protected right you just don't to
apply the rules to yourself I get it I
wouldn't either you know what I mean
I've care about protecting my feel let's
protect the kids first that seems that
much the starting house I agree
thank you very much my pleasure